a parís las visitas la cultura la comida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y el ruido durante décadas esta ha sido
una de las características de la ciudad
de la luz pero quizá no por mucho tiempo
más las autoridades instalaron el primer
radar de ruido como parte de un plan
para multar a los vehículos ruidosos
colgada de una farola en el este de
parís la máquina puede medir el nivel de
ruido de los autos y motos identificar
su matrícula el límite se fijará en 85
decibeles es decir 4 veces el nivel de
ruido que hace un camión al pasar
los vehículos que superen ese umbral
serán multados es como un radar de
velocidad la máquina toma
automáticamente una foto de la matrícula
del vehículo infractor si es demasiado
ruidosa plate iglesia ok the past
moondance soil aunque todos los
vehículos estarán sujetos a una multa
los principales culpables son algunos
propietarios de motos que modifican sus
vehículos lo que provoca más subido
según el ayuntamiento una moto ruidosa
circulando por la noche puede despertar
hasta a 10 mil parisinos y a lo largo de
los años los habitantes de la ciudad
pueden perder y ocho meses de esperanza
de vida
de adex gioja de dónde efe con este tipo
de radar queremos regular el tráfico y
liberar a nuestra ciudad del ruido sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que gran parte
de esos sonidos provienen de
comportamientos incívicos
yo comparto mucho de compost o
maastricht sin embargo todavía no se han
puesto multas esta semana se instalará
otra cámara en el oeste de parís si el
programa piloto funciona las autoridades
quieren empezar a multar a los
infractores y desplegar más de estos
radares